[Music]
well folks this is the last of the
videos of the series title against that
mixture the Neanderthal series and I
wanted to tie some loose ends some
things that may not have become clear
from informal chats with my son
especially I want to get get you to
think of the main points that I wanted
to get across and one of those is that
you know we were two different species
the Neanderthals and humans the
Neanderthals had a different type of
mitochondrial DNA we have we find no
mitochondrial known and although
mitochondrial DNA in humans today that
means we had no mother's because
mitochondrial DNA is passed on from
mother to child and if we have none well
that means uh you know we had known the
end of our mothers we have no
neanderthal chromosome y chromosomes
that means we had no Neanderthal fathers
either Y chromosomes are passed on from
father to son we have none and that
means we have no evidence that these no
objective evidence that we had any
endeth of father's in fact we have no
objective data showing that Neanderthals
and humans ever met so far we have not
been able to place humans and
Neanderthals at the same place at the
same time so there's no objective
evidence for any of those the only tiny
amount of evidence that you could say
and again that's stacked up against
admixture is that we have about 2
percent any human has about 2 percent
Neanderthal DNA in him and the question
is whether that 2 percent comes from
interbreeding
or from the fact that we have a common
ancestor
what happened allegedly 50,000 years ago
or so and the other one happened five
hundred thousand years or so ago so it's
a it's that's the question the question
is whether our two percent comes from
interbreeding or from a common ancestor
and you know you've got a there's a
there's a lot of playing around with the
numbers with the data and we find that
you know some people say but we have two
percent there's a study and I think
that's in video would number four talks
about the fact that we have maybe up to
seven percent and then they find this
boost ish in man in the middle of
Siberia and he's he's dated to about
forty five thousand years ago and he
also had 2.3 percent just like any human
today which again stacks up against
admixture and essentially we were two
different species we were two different
species by the definition of the word
species and I covered that subject in
what video number seven we were two
different species because we defined the
word species as successful interbreeding
as having fertile offspring and the
human race is said to have started two
hundred thousand years ago the human
species right it means that today no
human today would be able to interbreed
but whenever on our ancestors two
hundred thousand years ago in other
words two hundred thousand years ago we
have to put out as the cough date for
the species of humans anyone beyond that
anyone beat before that we could not
interbreed with today successfully
that's what it means that's what the
word specie would mean in what it really
means is that there's been so many
mutations since that time there's been
this genetic drift and so none of us
today would be able to interbreed
with one of our oldest ancestors maybe
200 you can even take it 250 300
thousand years ago but what does that
mean if that's true it means we could
not have interbred with someone 500 that
separate from our lineage 500,000 years
ago and that's the case of the
Neanderthals then and Athos by a forked
out from our or branched out from our
lineage say anywhere between 400 and 600
thousand years ago these numbers are
very the ranges are very wide but
assuming if we just take a number five
hundred thousand years ago we could not
today interbreed with anyone five
hundred thousand years ago from our own
minutes let alone from a parallel
lineage like the Neanderthals which
branched off and went into Europe into a
different environment so if the word
species means interbreeding successful
interbreeding having fertile offspring
we could not have it but then he went in
our own then it's two hundred thousand
years ago anyone beyond like to kind of
leave two hundred thousand years ago is
beyond our reach we cannot have sex with
successful children with it with someone
if that we could go to the past or they
could come into the future we could not
have successful children four top
children there are lots of different
species because the Neanderthals did
wear clothes and we did we were born
apparently in Africa and we migrated to
Europe that's the theory and that's that
the widely accepted and I think it's a
pretty good theory because we find no
human bones in Europe until about thirty
five thousand years ago and if that's
the case that means we went there found
it to be cold for us and we had to put
cold clothes on and as probably when we
invented clothes we had no need for
clothes until then and an end athel's
you know they they branched out from us
way back when in the days of Homo
erectus Homo erectus goes to Western
Europe goes to France goes to Spain goes
to England there was a passage
where the channel is today in those days
you could walk across any went all the
way to England we find human remains and
artifacts tools etc in Happisburgh and
pinks field England and from that line
from those Homo erectus in England
that's where the Nana
first the Homo heidelbergensis comes in
he's got about what is it about 1100 the
cc's 1200 CCS cubic centimeter in
cranial capacity and eventually ends up
evolving into Neanderthals and that
happened maybe anywhere between 400 and
600 thousand years ago five hundred
thousand is a good ballpark figure so so
so these fellows you know the first Homo
erectus who got the England he had no
clothes he could have survived in that
environment you know he survived in that
environment I mean without clothes he
didn't invent clothes I'm sure that
nobody's gonna argue that homo erectus
invented clothes and so how did he live
in England and so if the endeth all
descends from that homo erectus who goes
through Homo heidelbergensis and ends up
with Homo neanderthalensis all these
none of them had clothes but we did have
clothes so we would have not only notice
that their heads were a little different
because you know they had these big
heads big noses but they were nude and I
visualized them as very hairy gorillas I
think they had hair I don't think the
line that led to me and earth all lost
their hair and so I think they would
recognize each other as a separate
species
and that's very unlikely highly unlikely
that these two different animals would
have interbred
in the wild and then there's the other
issue of rape was this a one night stand
a few nanda those who had sex with a
assuming assuming no he had sex with
them right they almost all the papers
talk about limited interbreeding that
there was limited contact well what does
that mean is that rape one-night stand
you know you have sex one night and and
you had an offspring is that going to
cause the extinction of the Neanderthals
and I want to make sure that you
understand it and mixture is a is an
extinction theory he who doesn't
understand and has not understood the
first thing about it mixture admixture
is not a theory that says we had sex
with an Andrew Thals and that's why we
have 2% the DNA of their DNA in our body
no that's got nothing to do with that
the admixture theory is an extinction
theory let that be absolutely clear it
is is pushed by people like Eric tree
cows it's pushed by people who like
Wilford whop off and John Hawkes and
other famous names of Neanderthal
paleontology all these people believe
that the endo has disappeared because
they interbred with us so it is an
extinction theory ok and of course it
gave jobs to all the geneticists and so
they're absolutely happy with it but
then if it was a one-night stand who it
was rape in the bushes in the middle of
the jungle there with this caused the
extinction of the entire population of
nana thoughts and I think the answer is
no because you know what happened to the
other Nana so why did they continue
reproducing and earth offs purebred
Neanderthals they would still be around
so admixture did not cause the
extinction of the Neanderthals and
that's what it makes sure is claiming
that it did ok so look I want to make
those points I want to make sure that
you leave with those points
mine but this video is specifically
about its type political science and the
reason I titled it that way is because
when I want to focus on the politics
that was behind that mixture how they
push this interbreeding theory not only
to the top of the charts but spread it
around the world and made everyone
believe in it and I want to focus as
specific specifically on two points one
is the language that they used you look
at the language in the papers it's very
cautious you know they use words like
May and perhaps they suggest insinuate
but when they talk to the public it's a
done deal
the language is sweeping and I'm gonna
give you a little bit of information
that I'm gonna read a couple of things
from the literature so that you can
compare and contrast how they talk to
the public versus how they talk to their
peers and in the other one I want you to
be aware of is that you know a
geneticist is a liar
and that's the best thing I can say
about it he's a liar
what world is he lie well he lies in
first in claiming or giving you the
impression misleading you to believe
that genetics is an exact science it is
not what they're doing is packaging
opinion as truth as fact as a done deal
that's what they're doing that's what
the geneticists are doing then they hide
they lied when they hide data that
debunk their theories then they give you
the impression that well you know we
were skeptical of interbreeding but the
data just overwhelmed us and we had to
accept it and then they play around with
the numbers
you'll see how they play around with the
percentages again it's got to do with
with their opinions and not with
objective data or with genetics being in
a an exact science they played around
with the percentages and the fact that
all these geneticists come up with
different numbers and different ranges
in fact they have quite wide ranges in
many aspects this will give you an idea
this should give you an idea that you
know these people play around with the
numbers but then since people believe
that genetics is an exact science that
they can tell you what diseases we
inherited from the and a fault or
whatever then they you know these people
are like gods whatever comes out of
their mouth is truth and so this is what
the danger is so let's go with the first
one I want to show here this is from the
original genome paper 2010 and want you
to look focus on the cautious language
that the team that prepared the paper
the people who worked on the genome
project how they talk they talk very
cautiously and I want you to compare
that against some statements from the
literature where the stings are totally
you know we have sweeping statements
here's the first one
this comes again from Green 2010 that's
the original genome paper test the data
suggest that between 1 & 4 percent of
the genomes of people in Eurasia are
derived from Neanderthals the gene flow
between and a thousand modern humans
most likely occurred before the
divergence this may be explained by
mixing of early modern humans with Anna
those in the Middle East before their
expansion into Eurasia the analysis of
the Anantha thought genome shows that
they are likely they have had a role in
the genetic ancestry of present-day
humans ok very clear you look at the
words suggest most likely maybe
likely you know they have all this vague
language now compare this against how
these people talk to the public here's
one muskovitz in life science may 6 2010
the Neanderthals have not totally
extinct set study leaders Fonte Paabo of
the Max Planck Institute for
evolutionary anthropology in Leipzig
Germany in some of us they live on a
little bit there's another one from a
pub on one of his TED Talks 2011 today
people living outside Africa have about
2.5 percent of their DNA from the end of
dolls no offends or butts
you know it's straightforward here's
another one
Wii U 2014 our analysis shows that
modern humans had already interbred with
Neanderthals then and we can determine
when that first happened much more
precisely than we could before said Pavo
and final one here the Neanderthal
cinetic contributions the present-day
people seems to have larger
physiological effects and I would have
naively thought said Pablo okay so you
can see the contrast between the
languages how they talk to the peers
very cautiously because they know a lot
of peers gonna question them but the
public you know they just give sweeping
stable yeah we prove an end of it it's a
done deal you got accepted mixture Beco
we know and that's that's the danger so
that's politics that's got little to do
with science but that's how they sold
admixture to the public the next thing I
wanna show is the how they play with the
numbers and again I want you to look at
you know among other things how they
hide some of this data for example you
know I showed I think we'll listen in I
think it was in yeah in video four
through six one of those before
specifically and in that video
I show that the starting hypothesis that
the people from the genome project had
was that humans in Europe Europeans have
more Neanderthal DNA than Africans that
was a starting hypothesis and it turned
out to be apparently true that's what
the objective data showed but what they
hid from the public is that Asians
specifically Papua New Guineans
or pop ones and American Indians have
more Neanderthal DNA and Europeans and
so we got a problem because you know we
can't hide that data and just highlight
the fact that Europeans have more than
Africans we also have to explain if the
data shows that Asians and I'm American
Indians have more musical DNA than
Europeans we got explain that fact as
well so the way they hide it from the
public is by pitting not Africans they
bunch all of us in under non Africans
and they pit us against Africans so they
always talk you'll never hear ever again
them talking about you know Asians or
American Indian they'll just say look
not Africans have more DNA than Africans
and that proves our theory yeah but what
about the Asians they have more and with
all DNA that Europeans you haven't
explained that fact in a number will and
then they play around like I said a
minute ago they player up on the numbers
here's a statement also from the
original genome project it says the
actual amount of inner breeding between
Neanderthals and modern humans may have
been very limited again mean one-night
stand you know that's how they became
extinct given that it contributed only
one to four percent of the genome of
present-day non-africans here's another
one by proofer says using the hyper
coverage Neanderthal genome in
conjunction with the two other Nandalal
genomes we now estimate
that the proportion of Neanderthal
derive DNA and people outside Africa
again non-africans they never talk about
it never specify is one point five to
two point one percent so they went from
one to four percent to one point five to
two point one percent but then you have
a study by law said 2014 and he comes up
with a totally different number for
being an objective science genetics
really has quite a variety of values and
ranges in here you see it our analysis
reveals that strong support for an NFL
admixture in Eurasia at a higher rate
three point four to seven point three
percent that's suggested previously and
so again it shows that these people are
playing with the numbers but it turns
out that there was this who's dishing
man that they did the genome on he's a
human allegedly forty five thousand year
old human and it says we present the
high quality genome sequence of a
forty-five thousand year old modern
human male from Siberia we estimate that
the proportion of Neanderthal mixture in
the ischium individual individual to be
2 point 3 plus or minus three percent
similar to present-day East Asians and
present-day Europeans so what should we
conclude I mean if the Ossetian man was
a human and he was living forty five
thousand years ago we concede this right
and he had only two percent two point
three percent which is what most people
have today and if we take now law sees
number which he says it's up to seven
point three percent well how do we gain
and earth all DNA from forty thousand
years ago to the day how do you mean how
do we start out with two point three as
the host machine man had and ended up
with seven point three that Laxus says
some people have today how did they gain
yen dethalian a are there still
Neanderthals around living walking
around the streets so you can see that
that you have two points here the first
one is genetics it's not an exact
science because obviously they have all
these numbers and ranges and they see
more like opinions and objective facts
and then the second one is that you know
they have no way of explaining assuming
these numbers are correct we concede
them that how is it that we gained NAND
earth all DNA and of course they have
the ball in their Court they have to
explain this and we have another issue
and that's this this trick that there's
a spawn to Pavel he was the head of the
genome project and how they play around
with us they say look I was skeptical of
interbreeding I did believe in it but
you know that the data was overwhelming
I finally had to accept it
this is the way they present it to the
public and here let me show you some of
the the statements made throughout this
time in 2013 in decoding the
Neanderthals a Nova documentary slanty
Pablo says to follow he says I was
biased against interbreeding there was
no evidence for it so I don't think it
really happened now he said this in 2013
so he really he was talking in
retrospect so he you really meant I
didn't think it really happened now
that's very hard to believe let me tell
you why in 1997 Svante Paabo was named
head of the project and since then 1997
onwards he was trying to prove
mitochondrial DNA at all costs and
against all odds and he wasn't the only
group there were other groups doing the
same thing well I've got at least nine
studies in my hand and I think that's in
video number six no I'm sorry that's
video number three and in those studies
it's very clear that we have no
mitochondrial DNA known and although
mitochondria
and the question is you would say well
yeah after two or three tries it would
say given up and say well you know
there's we have we have known and athan
mitochondrial DNA why did they continue
running tests well because obviously
they were not skeptical they were trying
to prove interbreeding at all costs
that's why and by 2001 in 2007 ten years
later
Time magazine names Pablo is one of the
100 most influential individuals on
earth they did that because he he was
starting to the genome project for
Neanderthal and of course after finding
no no mitochondrial DNA they said well
let's try a nuclear DNA and of course
it's very highly highly highly unlikely
that they would have found no nuclear
DNA especially we had a common ancestor
and in fact they had to find the tiny
resident which is where we have today
well the only issue here was how we how
they how personal I guess what the Pablo
was going to interpret that data was he
going to interpret it saying yeah that 2
percent comes from our common ancestor
500 thousand years ago or was he going
to say it comes from interbreeding 50
thousand years ago and there was a big
difference because if we shared a common
ancestor of course we're gonna have
maybe 2 percent commonality and that's
different than saying that look humans
went into Europe we had sex and that's
how the Neanderthals disappeared and
that's why we have 2% today those are
two different theories of how we got our
2% and Ethel DNA and of course
Time magazine mentioned him or named him
as one of the most influential people
because they already realized that he
had a lot of power in his hand potential
power they knew that when he finished
the project he was going to come out
with some amount of nuclear
Neanderthal nuclear DNA in humans and so
they said this guy in three years we're
gonna put him you know he's gonna be or
Sevenfold so they were grooming him for
that
for that future moment when he put out
his report and when he put out his
report he leaned on the side of
admixture without any reason because if
there's no mitochondrial DNA there's
also no white chromosomes the end of the
white chromosome that means no human no
no human male today as a new Y
chromosome from ganda though and we only
have 2% DNA which could just as well and
probably did come from our common
ancestor well then we had nothing to do
with in the other thoughts but what
would that have left where would that
have left all the geneticists there
would have been without a job because if
if we never had the sex we never met the
Neanderthals after you know after we
separated from our minions 500,000 years
ago all geneticists since 2010 working
on endeth all DNA would be out of a job
they're working on nonsense of stuff
that has nothing to do with anything and
that's it that's the issue and and so
you see how these these people play
around with the numbers how they
manipulate the public just to get their
Theory across and endured and the bottom
line on all this is they have no
alternative theory for the extinction of
the nfl's if admixture dies they have to
go back to competition again involving
humans or that we killed them or that we
passed on diseases or who knows what or
climate change which is another one
that's so famous out there but I want to
end this with with a sweeping remark
that one of the members of Pablo's team
said in Nova documentary titled decoding
Neanderthals as Richard ed green he says
we were able to convince the world that
we have a little bit of endeth all in
our genes
so now you know what all that was about
it was about persuading convincing
converting recruiting that's what it was
about it's got to do with not science
it's got to do with political science
[Music]
Puka so what do you think to the geeks
that work at the Max Planck Institute
let me tell you what I think Vonda
[Music]
you